the goal of this video is to find the
solution set for
the following equation negative 6 times
the cosine
of 8x plus 4 is
equal to 5. and like always i encourage
you to pause this video and see if you
can have a go at this
before we do it together and a reminder
we want the entire solution set not just
one solution
all right now let's work through this
together some of you might recognize
that it would be valuable
to isolate the cosine of 8x
and a good way of doing that would be
first to subtract 4
from both sides and then that would get
us
negative 6 times cosine of 8x
i subtracted 4 from the left so that 4
is going to be gone
and then if i subtract 4 from the 5 from
the 5
i'm going to get a 1 there and now i can
multiply
both sides of this
equation by negative 1
6 i just want to be have a 1 in front of
the cosine so negative
1 6 and so this is going to be 1
so i'm just going to have cosine of
8 x is equal to negative 1
6. now if i just keep going i could take
the inverse cosine of negative 1
6 and whatever that is divide by 8 i
would get
a solution but this is a good time to
pause and to make sure
that we're capturing all of the
solutions and i'll
give us or i'll refresh our memories
with some identities
so and to help with these identities i
like to draw a quick
unit circle so this
is our x-axis this is our y-axis
and so my quick hand-drawn
unit circle is like
might look something like this it's not
that nice looking
but we want to think about all of the
angles that when i take the cosine i get
to negative 1 6.
so negative 1 6 might be something like
right over here and so you can see
that there might be an angle like this
that would get us there so let me draw
that draw the radius
we know the cosine of an angle is the
x-coordinate of where that radius that's
defined by
that angle where that radius intersects
the unit circle
but we also see there's another place if
we essentially take
the negative of that angle we could go
right over here
and we would also get the same cosine so
we could go the negative of the angle go
that way and that's where we get the
identity that cosine
of negative theta is equal to cosine
of theta and so if cosine of 8x
is equal to negative 1 6 using this
identity we also know that cosine of
the negative of this will also be equal
to negative 1 6.
so let me write that down cosine of
negative
8x is also going to be equal to
negative 1 6. now already we have
expanded our solution set
because this is going to give us another
x value that's going to get us the
result that we want
but are we done well the other thing to
realize
is let's say i have some angle here
where if i take the cosine i get to
negative 1
6 but then if i add 2 pi again i'm going
to get to the same place and the cosine
is once again going to be negative 1 6.
and i could add
2 pi again i could essentially add 2 pi
an
arbitrary integer number of times so i
could rewrite
this right over here as cosine
instead of just 8x it's 8x plus
an integer multiple of 2 pi that's also
going to be equal to
negative 1 6. and similarly for negative
8x
i could say cosine of negative
8x plus an integer multiple of 2 pi
n is going to be some integer in both of
these situations
that's also going to get us to negative
1 6. and so now we can feel pretty good
that we're capturing all
of the solutions when we solve for x so
in both of these now let's take the
inverse cosine of negative 1
6 in order to solve for x here
so if we were to take the inverse cosine
of both sides
we could get that x plus two pi
times some arbitrary integer n is equal
to
the inverse cosine of negative
one sixth and then now let's solve for x
we can subtract
two pi n from both sides so we could get
8 x is equal to the inverse cosine
of negative 1 6 minus
2 pi n now it's interesting to note that
the sign on this 2 pi
n term actually doesn't matter so much
because n could be a negative integer
but i'll just stick with this negative
2 pi n and so if we wanted to solve for
x we just divide both sides by 8
we get x is equal to 1 8
times the inverse cosine of negative 1
6 minus pi
over 4 n and now we can do the exact
same thing
in the other scenario i'll call this the
yellow scenario
where if i take the inverse cosine i get
negative 8 x
plus 2 pi n is equal to the
inverse cosine of negative 1
6 and now i can subtract 2 pi n from
both sides
so i get negative 8x is equal to
inverse cosine of negative 1 6
minus 2 pi n now i can multiply both
sides by negative 1 8 or divide both
sides by negative
8 and i get x is equal to negative
1 8 times the inverse cosine
of negative 1 6 plus
pi over 4 n
so i will stop here for this video or at
least algebraically we know the solution
set and this is the complete solution
set if you take the combination of both
of these
x if you take the combination of both of
these expressions
in a future video we'll evaluate this
with a calculator
and we'll think about the solutions that
fit within
a given interval